DeSantis is his own man and he's been a
great governor with his own record and
he's done a unbelievably good job and so
Trump started him on his legacy there
but it's kind of an interesting thing
right it's like I kind of made you who
you are
wait your turn and DeSantis said ah well
you got me past the primary but you
didn't make me a good governor
right and so that's desantis's claim
here's where I come down on it though my
advice to Ron DeSantis would be as of
right now you will not be the nominee
Trump is gaining support this indictment
helps him it validates every core
argument that Trump has which is the
system is against me therefore I'm such
a threat they're going to try to take me
out in a Republican primary you know
that plays really really well